Hey, can we stay with you?
The StubHub Center is hosting
a flipping soccer practice
Sorry, man, we’re in mourning
I let down my fantasy teams again!
Nobody fluffin respects us!
We’re the GD front-runners
for an AFC Wild Card!
Bruh, where are we?
KIKO!!
K-K-K-K-KIKO!
Welcome to the Florida section
of Gridiron Heights!
How have I never noticed this place?
Probably because it’s only for
underperforming teams with
with quarterback controversies
And bath salts!
Let me give you a tour—
I’ll take it from here
Since I’m the most Florida person
you’ll ever meet—
AHHHH!
And I’m back
Over here we have our own hospital
Why aren’t we getting better?!
Guess you needanother year to evaluate me!
And that’s where the Jags D practices
OK, why am I the only one who showed up?
That’s our house!
Woah
We built it in ‘72 and
have sort of coasted since then
So where do you guys want to eat?
P-Rivs, let’s go home
Stay!
You can be the Kissimmee Chargers
and play inside the Medieval Times!
We need stars here
We’ve been starting a manatee
at left tackle for years
L.A. CAN KISS MY TUCKUS!
I’M STAYING HERE!
But we just signed a thousand-year lease!
I’M MAKING ANOTHER CULTURE CHANGE
EVERYONE, OUT
Yeah, OK, let’s leave